ensuite malheureusement à la force de
frappe économique des américains je
rappelle que netflix parents investi 15
milliards de dollars dans les
productions
nous ne pouvons pas faire face à ça ni
français ni européen
je rappelle quand même avant l'existence
des plateformes la france
traditionnellement était le troisième
pays au monde comme force
cinématographique et premier pays au
monde à produire et coproduire les
meilleurs cinéastes du monde et d'europe
au niveau du cinéma ce qu'on appelle de
la diversité donc si on perd cette
capacité de la france
les cinéastes du monde entier vont se
ressentir et donc la diversité de la
pensée à travers le cinéma donc la
démocratie va s'en ressentir
et depuis toujours depuis l'exception
culturelle et même avant notre
philosophie avec tous les partenaires
qui sont si puissants c'est du donnant
donnant vous voulez nos abonnés netflix
à 8 millions d'abonnés en france il n'y
a pas de problème le marché est ouvert
alors que dans d'autres pays les très
fermé le marché est ouvert mais en
échange vous pouvez pas nous abreuver
que deux oeuvres américaines
éduquer nos publics qu aux oeuvres
américaines en échange ya deux aspects
de la directive bien il ya une
imposition de catalogue de 30 % à
l'intérieur de tous les catalogues
d'oeuvres européennes ce qui est
important que les européens voient aussi
des oeuvres européennes et ensuite y
aller les obligations d'investissement
et là aussi à une nuance les 20% que la
france va imposer sur les 20%
y a que 20 % de ses 20% qui vont au
cinéma
[Musique]